we all belong to the same continent
who all share the same values and there
ore these countries it is us and our value
that are attacked it is not especially
he French the English the Italian
17 nationalities are among the d
ad in the bataclan all the Paris attac
s  since it's not just
the bataclan that we have to share our
experience so that we can design
together ways to deal with the
threat and the people who are in front of
us are men who imagine
how they can hurt us
in this directory of the possibilities of
action of the processes to do this to
catch up with it could ensure that
the consequences are the
least horrible months possible
the paris fire brigade
is a military unit it is a
particularity of 8500 men and women
who has jurisdiction for both the
fires and the rescue of victims
throughout the Paris region
I think that no one is immune
to an attack he  we have to prepare and
that's what we are doing but we have
improved our interoperability in
particular to extract
victims who would be stranded in an
area in which there are still
terrorists an area which is not
entirely secure I have already  invited
my colleagues from the european union to
paris we did a complete fing bubble
of what we had done we have
frequent exchanges with our friends in
brussels especially after the attacks
they suffered so this cooperation
is being set up
very  I regularly meet my
colleagues from other European capitals
and the next meeting will take
place in Zagreb